[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previous
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Doug Bachelor
Hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact redwood trees in California
hold the records for both the tallest
and the largest trees in the world
one coastal redwood is 380 ft tall and
the General Sherman seoa near yede
contains an incredible
52,500 cubic feet because of heavy
logging redwoods are now classified as
endangered sadly 95% of California's
original old growth redwoods are gone
yet at the same time they were being cut
down in California they were taking rot
in another land because they are
naturally resistant to rot and fire seoa
redwoods were first imported to the UK
as seeds and seedlings in
1853 at the time the trees became a
symbol of wealth and power in the
Victoria era Britain redwoods were
increasingly used to line the roads and
Landscape Parks the trees seemed to
thrive in the Rainy climate and The Fad
continued for a 100 years now the giant
redwood trees that are endangered in
California are thriving in the UK a
survey has recently shown there are
currently some 500,000 redwoods across
the British Countryside by comparison
did you know there's only about 880,000
mature giant redwoods in their native
range of
California you know the Bible talks
about transplants that are flourishing
in a foreign environment that's right
Pastor D you know spoke about redwoods
sequa giant I know you have and I have
we've been there to close to yed where
they have a Grove of the Giants seoa
trees it is humbling just standing next
to one of these giant trees and looking
up it's it's truly an amazing tree um
it's one of my favorite trees yeah and
of course you always associate these
giant trees with Northern California
which the climate and the history and
all the rest of it it is interesting
though that you have the same tree now
that is flourishing far away from
Northern California all the way over in
Great Britain that's right and you know
folks might wonder well Pastor Doug you
usually tie these amazing facts to some
biblical truth Truth where are you going
to go with this mhm you know folks you
might be surprised to know that for
almost 2,000 years Jehovah re revealed
himself and worked through and operated
through the Jewish Nation Israel but
after the time of Christ and Jesus said
this would happen the gospel exploded
from Pentecost where all the Jews had
gathered they took the gospel back to
their respective countries and in one
century the majority of people now
believing in Jehovah were no longer
Jewish the the religion of the true God
had spread far beyond the borders of
Israel and so that you know today the
the amount of people reading the Bible
uh I think there's 16 million Jews in
the world approximately I think half of
them are in Israel and approximately and
the other half are in the US well I
should
say you know 45% in Israel 45% in the US
and the others are scattered around
around the world but um there's two
billion people in the world that believe
the Bible that are Christians and it's
spread far beyond the religion that
began in Israel has spread far beyond
the borders it's interesting that you
consider the Bible tells us that
Christianity is really an extension of
Judaism you know Paul said this was
going to happen you can read in Romans
9:25 as he says in Hosea Paul is quoting
the old test
I will call them my people who were not
my people and her beloved who is not
beloved and it will come to pass in the
place where it was said of them you are
not my people there they shall be called
the Sons of the Living God and so the
gospel then went to the Gentiles and now
you've got this whole nation of
spiritual Jews that are scattered around
the world and we have a free offer that
talks about that that's right people
often ask well what about Israel in
Bible prophecy what does the bible teach
we've got a book it's called spiritual
Israel and it explores this very subject
who is Israel at least spiritual Israel
today we'll be happy to send you the
book the number to call for that is 800
835 6747 that is our resource phone line
you can just ask for the book by name
spiritual Israel you can also get it by
simply dialing pound 250 on your phone
pound 250 say Bible answers live and
then say spiritual Israel and we'll send
you that book a digital copy of the book
If you have a Bible question our phone
line here to the studio is 800 463
7297 that'll bring your call in to our
our phone operators again it's 800 463
7297 well before we go to the phone
lines Pastor Doug we always start with
prayer let's do that now dear father
what a joy it is to be able to spend
time in your word once again and open up
the scriptures and we just pray for your
spirit we know the Bible is your book
lord and be with those who are listening
wherever they might be if they're in
their car at home and just lead us into
a clearer understanding standing of the
Bible we thank you in jesus' name amen
amen all right we are ready for our
first call we got Gary in Illinois Gary
welcome to Bible ances
live thank you in Exodus 19 verse1 16 it
says on the morning of the third day
there were Thunders Lightnings and a
thick Cloud on the mountain and a very
loud trumpet blast so that all the
people in the camp trembled so my
question is is God preparing us for a
significant event as he did Israel when
he was giving them the Ten Commandments
today there are uh dozens of videos with
trumpets uh sounding in the sky people
are asking what are those trumpets you
know and so that's my question all right
hey thank you well it is true that there
are trumpets compared with the last days
uh not only do you have seven trumpets
in Revelation that span the course of
military history that of the Christian
era uh but you know there may be some
trumpets that are going to be blowing
right at the end of time sort of like
when the um before Jericho fell uh
Joshua sent the priests out ahead of the
army blowing seven trumpets so of course
the Lord's going to descend from heaven
with the voice of the Archangel and the
Trump of God now the trumpets that
you're hearing people talk about on
YouTubes I would have to say I've Not
Seen Those so um there may be signs and
things happening in the heavens it says
that in Luke um no question about that
definitely seems our skies are getting
more noisy just with all of the travel
taking place and different types of
aircraft and planes I know we hear
helicopters fly over all the time and
jets becomes pretty noisy just listening
up to what's happening in the sky
haven't heard a trumpet though but uh
you know there's a lot of noise just's
think about all of the radio signals and
cell phone signals M and television
signals that are going through the air
at this moment it's amazing that we're
not all
microwaved with all that all right thank
you Gary we got Britney listening in
California Britney welcome to the
program yeah my question is why did
Peter cut up the ear of matus when he
knew that Jesus was able to heal people
well I I think that uh the the apostles
were thinking that Jesus was going to do
something to set himself up as an
Earthly King and that's why James and
John said when you're in your kingdom
can we sit on the right and left of your
throne they were picturing Jesus not as
reigning from Heaven not as a spiritual
Kingdom and in fact even after the
resurrection I think Philip said Lord
will you at this time establish the
kingdom and so when they came to arrest
Jesus Peter maybe thought well this is
going to be the um the the nuclear
moment that's going to change everything
and that they were supposed to take up
arms so um I don't think that they
thought Jesus was going to go through
the battlefield healing everybody I
think they thought that this was a
pivotal moment when they would uh fight
and Jesus would assert his power to make
himself King you know there's several
times according scripture where the mob
and there was times when the disciples
thought that they needed to um Force
Christ so to speak to be king to take on
some position when he fed the 5,000
and there was people felt you know we
need to make him King and I'm sure the
disciples were part of that plot and
Jesus finally sent them on a ship to
cross the lake M and here maybe like you
say the disciples might think well the
time has come you it's the Passover
everyone's coming to Jerusalem he
already entered the city riding on on
the back of a donkey and there was
connected with a king and and I don't
know though if Peter was really thinking
right there he just responded he just
reacted yeah no one had ever really laid
hands on Jesus to arrest him before and
so that's why before they went to the
dinner they they said Lord we have two
swords and he said you don't get it he
said enough of this anyway all right
well thank you Britney appreciate your
question yeah we got uh tah listening in
New York tah welcome to the
program hello my question is are
dinosaurs
real yes dinosaurs are real um when I
grew up you sound like a young man I
grew up across the street street from
the Museum of Natural History in um New
York City and I used to go over there
and I wanted to be a
paleontologist and I'd look at all the
dinosaur bones and yeah they were very
real uh the dinosaurs just lived
contemporaneous that means at the same
time as people and so um there's been a
lot of confusion about the dating
methods recently they found dinosaur
bones the the thigh bone of a
Tyrannosaurus rex that still had soft
tissue it certainly could not be 65
million years old and the person who
discovered that was you know an atheist
paleontologist they admitted as they had
no religious agenda so um yeah the
dinosaurs did live on the Ark of Noah
they didn't take great big full-grown
brontosauruses or triceratops or
stegosauruses they probably took small
ones and they could have taken eggs or
babies so I think a lot of the animals
when they put them in the ark they
didn't need to take full grown ones and
of course After the flood then the
environment changed to the point where
these animals couldn't flourish anymore
yeah that are people like Nimrod the
hunter killed them off but we still have
great reptiles you know there's kimodo
dragons and there's some big crocodiles
in the Nile and a dinosaur is just a
very large reptile that's extinct but we
still have big reptiles okay we got
Manuel listening in Illinois Manuel
welcome to the program hello my question
is what's the best explanation or the
nearest interpretation of col iians
2:16 all right well let me read this for
our friends that are listening
Colossians
2:16 so let no one judge you in food or
in drink or regarding a festival or new
moon or sabbaths which are a shadow of
things to come but the substances of
Christ now some people have read
Colossians 21:16 and they're saying oh
you don't need to worry about the
Sabbath it says right there don't let
anyone judge you regarding the new moon
or sabbaths well the key is it's a
Sabbath which are a shadow there were
sabbaths that were created after sin
there were annual sabbaths that were
Shadows pointing to Christ it's not
talking here about this the Sabbath day
is singular it's not plural it's uh the
day that goes back before there was sin
right there at the beginning on the
seventh day of creation God made the
Sabbath day and Jesus said he made it
for man not for Jews but for Humanity
Christ said the Sabbath is made for man
that anthropos like anthropology the
human race everyone needs a Sabbath
everyone needs a day of rest the Jewish
annual sabbaths were nailed to the cross
and this is what Colossians 2:16 is
talking about has nothing to do with a
weekly day of worship or rest you know
we do have a study guide called The Lost
day of history and it talks about the
Sabbath and what the Bible has to say
about it we'll be able to send it to
anyone who calls and asks the number to
call for that is 800 835
6747 you can ask for the study guide is
called the last day of history no pound
250 and ask for it by name uh you can
also ask to sign up for free to the
amazing facts Bible school and you
actually go through all of these lessons
dealing with a number of very important
Bible topics so you can also ask when
you call to be enrolled in the free
amazing facts of Bible school next
caller that we have is Isaiah in Texas
Isaiah welcome to the program good
evening pastors uh thank you both for
what you do um
my question tonight is
um how can we um trust denominational
writings and is an example of uh Ellen
White well if you read in 1 Corinthians
chapter 12 and chapter 14 Paul makes it
very clear that the gift of Prophecy is
still something that God uses when you
look in Revelation 12 it says in verse
17 that the dragon the devil is wroth
with the remnant of her seed the church
he goes he's wroth with a woman he goes
to make war with the remnant of her seed
that has that keeps the Commandments of
God and has the testimony of Jesus if
you look in Revelation 19:10 it says the
testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
Prophecy and so the the law and the
prophets God you know it goes all the
way through history you read in Joel
chapter 2 it'll come to pass in the last
days I'll pour out my spirit on All
Flesh your sons and your daughters will
dream dreams they'll
prophesy and that's also quoted in Acts
chapter 2 so does God still inspire
people and speak through people in the
last days and I think you know
unequivocally the Bible says yes now
does that mean that that is to be added
to the scripture and put on the same
level as the scripture No categorically
no uh the scriptures are complete but
there's a distinction to say that God
does not inspire
or that God does not speak through
people is a different issue and so uh I
believe Ellen White fits in that
category of someone who is inspired and
for those out there who don't know who
that is and would question that I'd say
taste and see for yourself you know read
a book like steps to Christ and see if
it doesn't um support biblical truth and
there's there's biblical tests I think
we got a lesson that talks about that
there there's a series of biblical tests
that you can apply why to find out if a
person meets the criteria of what is the
definition of prophecy and I think the
point you make is important when it
comes to anyone who claims to be a
prophet or have a message from God it
needs to be tested by the Bible the
Bible says to the law and to the
testimony if they speak not according to
this there is no light in them so the
Bible is to be the test but having said
that we need to recognize that God does
still speak through people yeah
especially to guide in certain
circumstances we do have a study guide
It's called does God inspire psychics
astrologist and psychics that is one of
our study guides and deals with the
subject we'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800 835
6747 you can also di pound 250 on your
phone ask for the study guide does God
Inspire psychics that's probably the
that's all that'll need to be able to
find that lesson we'll be happy to send
it to you and read it and share it with
somebody else next caller that we have
is Shannon listening in Georgia Shannon
welcome to the program hi um my question
is on acts uh
23:6 and it says that Paul's um parents
were both Jews but then it says that he
was born of Pharisees could you please
explain
that yeah uh well the Pharisees were all
Jewish so there's no conflict there
matter of fact um I can't think of a
Pharisee that wasn't also Jewish by the
way the Hebrews are different from Jews
you could be Hebrew and maybe from the
tribe of isar the Jews were typically
from the tribe of Judah Benjamin and
Levites could be called Jews but it's a
derivative from the word Judah the 10
tribes were carried away captive uh Paul
was from The Tribe of Benjamin but so he
was also a Jew um but um yeah the the
Pharisees were a sect within Judaism
that was extremely rigorous and
fastidious about keeping the uh the the
law of Moses
okay very good we've got uh Aiden
listening in Arizona Aiden welcome to
the program hello pastors hi yeah real
quick um you two are going to stand out
in heaven your crowns are going to be so
heavy that the prophets are going to say
who are these guys oh I I hope I'm just
there that that'll be happy for that I
believe you're gonna make it brother
anyway my question is it's in
Revelations 13 ver8
and it says all who dwell on the earth
will worship Him whose names have not
been written in the Book of Life and so
there is have not been written and so my
question is if our names are written in
the Book of Life are we protected
somehow from
worshiping well you know of course if
you are a follower of Christ the Bible
says that um you know you can be sealed
and God said it if it were possible even
the very elect would be deceived but you
know God's people that are surrendered
to them him he will keep them of all
that the father gives me I will lose
nothing Jesus will keep us and so if
we're living lives of consecration to
God and we are our names are in the Book
of Life I believe we will be sealed and
kept um there are people that sometimes
their names are in the book of life and
where is it in Revelation he says I will
not blot their names out both in
Revelation and even Moses said you know
um you can blot a name out of the book
of life so some may have their names
removed that's Revelation 3:5 it says he
overcomes shall be clothed in white
garment and I will not blot his name out
of The Book of Life yeah so I think
everybody that is kept during the final
plagues their names are in the book and
they're kept by God right during that
time so your names get entered into the
book when you receive Jesus as your
personal savior but if you turn away
from him it does appear from this
passage that your name can be blotted
out of the book yeah and if your name is
out of the book well then you're subject
to worshiping the beast power as we read
about in Revelation chap 13 so we want
our names to remain in the Lamb's Book
of Life amen all right next caller that
we have is Chandler listening in
California Chandler welcome to the
program hi my question is when um Moses
went up to the burning bush and he had
to take off his shoes did they have to
take off their shoes in the Holy place
in the most holy Place yeah good
question um I don't know that there's a
comment the priest would wash their feet
and their hands in the labor and it may
be that you know it's not mentioned I
doubt it had a dirt floor my guess is
there were some carpets because they
they use Carpets in the tents my guess
is there were some carpets in there and
it may be that as the priest entered the
holy place that they were Barefoot it
would make sense if they had to wash
their feet before going in that they
probably wouldn't put on their dirty
sandals afterwards it would appear that
they would probably go barefoot with
their feet washed into the holy place
and of course when you get to Solomon's
Temple then it it had a floor that was
um you know with gold everywhere so
they'd walk on that special floor when
they walked in and they probably
wouldn't wear shoes and of course we've
been to the Middle East and we've been
over in that part of the world and still
today the custom exists that when you
going to a place of worship a church you
remove your shoes and you go in you know
with your socks or Barefoot it's a sign
of reverence yeah even today if you go
to the Dome of the Rock the site where
the temple used to be take your shoes
off and when we go to church in India m
a lot of several places you take your
shoes off so absolutely okay thank you
we've got Virginia listening California
Virginia welcome to the program hi good
evening evening um my question is what
does pure or what does um surrender or
total surrender mean like should I not
be watching movies or certain music or I
can watch some that are like you know
more like cooking shows or some what is
a total
surrender well total surrender would
mean you're willing to do whatever God
wants you to do and so in every
situation you would say not my will thy
will be done now that would mean yet you
apply a Biblical test to your life um
Paul says whatever things are noble just
pure that was is it Philippians 4 he
says think on these things so if it's a
TV program you want to ask is it Noble
just pure we not too many programs pass
that criteria and U you can always ask
what would Jesus do a Christian's a
follower of Christ um there's a Prayer
in the Bible I I the the fellow who
first uttered the prayer
um I I don't have much confidence in
Ahab but actually he made a statement he
said all that I am and all that I have
are yours and that is actually a very
good statement
all that I am and all that I have is
yours that would be total surrender
that's why Jesus said we deny ourselves
take up our cross and follow him and
sometimes that might mean deny something
that we're listening to or watching or
eating or spending money on or whatever
it is you know the verse you're
referring to Pastor Philippians 4:8 it
says finally Brethren whatever things
are true whatever things are noble
whatever things are just whatever things
are pure whatever things are lovely
whatever things are of good rep support
if there be any virtue if there be any
praise meditate on these things MH so
that's good counsel you know we do have
a book it's called life in the spirit
and it talks a little bit about living
that Victorious uh Spirit-filled Life
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks the number is 800 835
6747 you can also di pound 250 and ask
for the book it's called life in the
spirit we'll send it to you you can get
a digital download if you're outside of
North America just go to the website
amazingfacts.org
and you'll be able to read the book
there at the media library next caller
that we have is Jerry in Georgia Jerry
welcome to the program hello hi Jerry
you're on I was just wondering what the
world would be like after probation
closes well you can read in Matthew 12
that says at that time this is verse one
Michael will stand up the great Prince
that stands for the children of thy
people and there will be a time of
trouble such as there never has been
ever since was a nation even un the same
time so there is a great time of trouble
when Michael stands up that's when
Christ ceases his intercession and he
stands as though he's preparing to come
he stands as though judgment is has uh
been completed and there's a great time
of trouble so um he also Jesus mentions
that in Matthew 24 time of trouble such
as there never has been so this is the
time of Revelation 15- 16 when the seven
last plagues are poured out now that
hasn't started yet you know because it
says the oceans and the rivers turn to
blood but um it's coming and uh that's
why we want to have our names written in
that book
now all right very good we've got
Christopher listening in California
Christopher welcome to the program
you're on the
air hello good evening
evening uh my question is would it be
wrong to do boxing as self-defense not
to do professionally just to
train well I don't know if I can give a
unbiased answer because when I was a kid
my mother dated a a boxer for a while
and he gave my brother and I gloves and
a few lessons and and I always enjoyed
it but you have to ask yourself you what
would Jesus do as we just said a minute
ago it's hard for me you know I
sometimes I'll see a boxing match you
know you're you're surfing through the
channels you see it and I I want to
watch and if I watch for a minute then I
notice I get all excited just violent
you know you really you get two guys
trying to bludge into each other and
knock the other one senseless but um you
hope you never be in a situation where
you need to use boxing or any kind of
martial arts to defend yourself I think
there's probably good things you can do
for
exercise and um I know I used to wrestle
with my kids so that's a little more a
little different than trying to knock
someone out you ever a wrestle with your
boy Johan oh time yeah not anymore
they're too big they're too big he don't
go away friends we're coming back
hopefully that gave you some answer for
your question we're going to have more
Bible questions more Bible answers in
just a few moments after these important
[Music]
messages stay tuned Bible answers live
will return shortly
[Music]
my parents got divorced and I was three
or four and then I was basically
unchurched most of my life I had a
girlfriend in high school telling me
that she had to break up with me because
I wasn't a Christian I thought that's
weird I believe in God why would she say
that not realizing I was living a
horrible life with foul language was
mean and other stuff and that kind of
challenged me initially and then my dad
9/11 woke him up uh that he wasn't ready
to meet his Lord though he was a man
that I valued and knew loved me didn't
doubt that but he just knew he needed
more so he started watching TV
Ministries first uh Baptist preachers
and others and he was kind of intrigued
by what he was learning and so when he
turned me on to this this television
station first thing that I got access to
was Doug bachelor's most amazing
prophecy series that he did in Baran
Springs Michigan and I remember when I
first watched this my background was
Baptist is of sorts but I remember when
I first watched this
series I remember thinking I've never
heard that before about the state of the
dead or about the Sabbath or the
Commandments or the Rapture or other
things and I remember thinking to myself
I've never heard that before but that's
what the text says and that kept
happening and I had this experience of
just wondering like well what else have
I believed that isn't as it is you know
and the more I watched the more helpful
it became but again he kind of took a
different perspective on the messages it
was fresh to me but I just these things
I had never heard before and I just
realized like there's so much stuff in
the Bible that no one's t talking about
and that people need to know and so I
ended up in this awkward situation that
some of my friends who didn't believe
what I was coming to believe I didn't
know how to communicate with them and so
one of the things that helped me
initially was the sabbathtruth.com
website the truth about hell.com and the
truth about death and some of those
resource websites and amazing facts have
put together that were just full of
resources if I needed an answer to
something that someone brought up there
would be a 95% chance
that amazing facts would have something
that I could use it makes witnessing
even easier in that sense uh the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible was my first
uh real Bible that I had of of a more
trusted translation the Bible study
guides were in the back of it they had a
lot of other resources that were helpful
if you can hand a book to somebody and
you can pick up a phone and call amazing
facts you have everything you need and
so I was just printing off stuff and
handing it to people you know like
here's here's what I'm coming to realize
this is true it's in the Bible and was a
huge blessing to me and a real help just
to kind of help me to better understand
what the message was and understand it
for myself and have resources to put in
hand to other people it was invaluable
some time went by I eventually went to a
school of evangelism and was baptized
and then I had this amazing opportunity
that after being in Ministry for about
five or six years Doug Bacher was going
to be the main speaker at a youth event
and I was actually doing a seminar at
this Youth Event and it was just this
amazing kind of Full Circle experience
that the first person that I came in
contact with with in adventism to hear
the message to have it make sense to be
able to do ministry together with them
uh in whatever role possible just meant
the world to me and to be able to tell
him my story and tell him thank you was
invaluable and so uh God just gave me a
precious gift in affording that
opportunity and I'll never forget that
my name is D thank you for changing my
[Music]
life you're listening to Bible and
ansers live where every question
answered provides a clearer picture of
God and his plan to save you so what are
you waiting for get practical answers
about the good book for a better life
today this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends to
Bible answers live and we're so thankful
that you have remained with us some have
joined us along the way this is a live
interactive International Bible study
and you're invited to call in with your
questions that number once again is 800
God says that's 800
46372 N7 we are streaming on Amazing
Facts Facebook Doug Bachelor Facebook
Amazing Facts YouTube and we're on
aftv in Good News television and so
we're on a number of stations
rebroadcasts on 3abn and if you've got a
Bible question give us a call Who's Next
by the way my name is Doug Bachelor my
name is Jean Ross and we've got Russell
listening um in California and here a
question about the pool of Bethesda
Russell welcome to the
program hi pastors thank you for taking
my question my question is did the angel
of the Lord really stir the pool of
Bethesda all right well the some of you
know the story here it's in the Gospel
of John I think it's chapter 5 and it
says that um the people would gather
around this pool sitting on the porch
and they were all manner of sick people
and they'd see the water bubble or stir
somehow and they had a belief that an
angel had troubled the water and whoever
got in first was healed well I think
that John is relating what the legend
was I can't imagine that an angel of God
would find any joy in stirring the water
and watching people clamber over each
other to be the first one in uh that
would seem kind of like a cruel Pastime
so uh I don't believe the angel of the
Lord was doing that I think it's just
saying that they had a belief it was a
legend it was a local myth kind of like
they got the the the Waters of Lords
where people go and they think if if
they can just be there or number of holy
sites it had become a uh tradition and
but it wasn't actually God's angel that
was doing that yeah some have even
suggested with the archaeological you
know they found the PO the the pool of
Bethesda there and they actually did
archaeological digs and they found the
archers around there and some think that
they were Springs close by or under the
pool that fed the pool maybe every now
and again there would be some sort of a
ripple or a bubble that would arise or
something like that I've got Springs and
every now and then for you see bubbles
come up so could have been all right
thank you next caller that we have is
Bruce Bruce listening in uh North
Carolina and he's got a question about
not being under the law but under grace
Bruce welcome to the
program thank you pastors I uh just
wanted to ask I did AFCO online and
under the section for answering
objections how does one respond to we're
not under the law anymore but we're
under
grace well we are under grace but what
does that mean does being under grace
mean you no longer need to obey God's
law well Paul actually asks that
question in Romans and he says I think
it's chapter six he says God forbid how
shall we who are dead to sin live any
longer so when it says under the law
Paul is talking about those who because
they've broken the law that's all of us
the penalty is death we are under the
death penalty of the law but through
Jesus Mercy he washes us from our sin we
are forgiven we are no longer living
under a death penalty of the law because
we are now living under grace but being
under grace does not mean you no longer
have an obligation to obey the law
indeed those who are under grace are the
most eager to do God's will and obey the
law so we have a free book actually that
talks about does God's grace blot out
the law that answers that with a lot
more scripture too if you'd like to
receive the book just call and ask for
it the number is 800
83567 47 you can ask for the book does
God's grace blot out the law you can
dial pound 250 on your phone and say
Bible answers live and then ask for the
book does God's grace blot out the law
you'll be able to get a digital download
of the book if you're outside of North
America visit the website
amazingfacts.org next caller that we
have is Lee listening in Texas and uh he
has a question about uh The Garden of
Gethsemane and what Jesus prayed Lee
welcome to the program yes my question
is when Jesus prayed him in the garden
of gethe asking God to take this take
the cup from him why was he afraid to
him going to die if he knew he was going
to come back well I don't think Jesus
was afraid of death the the thing that
uh terrified him if that's the right
word that he was most anxious about is
this would be the first time he had been
separated from the father now keep in
mind that Christ is love God is love God
the Father God the son their very
essence of their nature is love which
they had expressed together from
eternity past and now if it's probably
incomprehensible for us that for the
first time in
eternity God the father and the son
would be separated ated and I think
looking at that and knowing that he
would be bearing sin and Christ was
going to be facing death the way a lost
person faces the second death he felt
the hopelessness that the Lost feel and
so that's why he said if there's any
other way that this cup might pass from
me I think compared to the the mental
suffering the physical suffering was
small the anguish that he felt about
being separated from the father not
death is what I think was uh weight
heavily on it the most heavily on his
heart absolutely all right thank you Lee
we've got Allan listening in North
Carolina and he's got a question about
the the first miracle that Jesus
performed turning W into wine oh thanks
for taking my call pastors good evening
to you I was just wondering about that
first miracle Jesus seemed bit reluctant
and also it seemed less significant and
profound than the other miracles of
raising the dead and healing the blind
and other things he did I just wonder if
there's some more significance to that
turning water into wine that I don't
guess yeah well I think so um I'll give
you a couple things quickly first of all
the the wine Jesus tells us at the end
of his life is a symbol of the blood of
the Covenant and turning the water into
the wine um the first plague that Moses
enacted upon the Pharaoh was turning the
water into blood
of the river Christ and that was the
beginning of their Deliverance that was
the first plague that ultimately ended
with their freedom from Egypt Christ's
first miracle is turning water into wine
which he says is a symbol of his blood U
the last thing that Jesus does on the
cross is the people give him sour wine
after he said I thirst that it it was
Sour it was not good he saved good wine
at the wedding he take sour wine on the
cross it's almost as though he gives us
his and takes ours it's like a blood
transfusion and so there's great
significance here when when he didn't
downplay it but when his mother told him
they're out of wine he said woman my
hour is not yet come she thought that
this miracle could be the context of
somehow announcing his
messiahship and he was letting her know
know one more thing I think it's
significant that a creation began with a
marriage in the garden and the first
miracle of Christ was to condone or to
bless a
wedding and um Jesus still wants to
bless marriages today and of course if
you look at the broader context you have
a marriage you have Christ and then the
church being his bride that's right and
in order for that to take place you had
to have the crucifixion symbolized by
the juice or the wine and then it says
the governor of the feast had to give
his approval and so after Christ rose
from the dead when he met Mary he saido
not cling to me I have not yet appeared
to my Father in heaven so uh that first
miracle I think is is lots of
profound uh you know significance in
revealing Christ's Mission and and what
he was here on Earth to do it's a great
I feel sermon coming on I there's a lot
there that's a great study that's good
all right thank you Alan we got Joanne
in Arizona Joanne welcome to the program
thank you what does that mean by very
few will make it through the eye of the
needle yeah Jesus said it's harder for a
rich man to go to heaven than is for a
camel to go through the eye of a needle
and well first of all Jesus can save
rich people because right after he makes
that statement in Luke it tells about
zakus who is very rich being saved and
of course you know there'll be people
there's are exceptions it's it's harder
for rich people to be saved because they
start trusting in their riches um but
you do have people like David and
Solomon and Abraham and Jacob that had
great substance and they'll be in the
Kingdom um there's a warning God said to
the children of Israel when you are
blessed and you're living in houses you
didn't build and eating from Vineyards
and drinking from Wells and you become
fat don't forget about the Lord and
there's a danger that we start trusting
in ourselves and our stuff and security
and we stop praying so the eye of a
needle though uh that was well there's a
couple of
theories there was uh a place in ancient
Hebrew when the Shepherds were counting
the Sheep
they had a narrow gate that only one
sheep at a time could go through so they
could count a large flock and they call
it threading them through the eye of the
needle so they're saying well for a
camel to go through the eye of a needle
it could do it but it'd have to get on
its knees and be totally unloaded and
it's basically Jesus way of saying yeah
Rich Man can get to the kingdom but he
has he has to be willing to put all
things in God's hands um and he could
also just be using a metaphor you know
Jesus said if you got a PL l in your eye
and you say to your friend help me get
the piece of dust out of your eye well
that's called irony pardon the pun so uh
he may have just been using the irony of
trying to picture a camel going through
the eye of a
needle okay thank you we've got uh
Marvins listening in Canada and he has a
question about the Antichrist power of
Revelation 13 Marvins welcome to the
program yes hello Pastor is the BC BC
the only Antichrist according to
Revelation 13 or can there be several
Antichrist according to one John 2 verse
uh 18 to uh
22 Yeah the um in first John matter of
fact you don't find the word Antichrist
in the Book of Revelation you find the
person or the power of the Antichrist in
Revelation the word Antichrist is
mentioned in first John he said yeah
there are many antichrists so in a
broader sense uh you know a power that
is working against Christ is Antichrist
you're just you're opposing the work and
the spirit of Christ that means you're
against Christ but then there was a big
prophetic Antichrist that's mentioned in
Prophecy and for 500 years Protestants
have identified the papacy as that
Antichrist when the Christian Church
lost its Simplicity and Purity and
became a political power and you know a
lot of money and kind of adopted
idolatry from the Romans they felt like
the church went through a great
compromise and it it fulfilled that many
of the prophecies that talk about what
the Antichrist would become yeah it's
interesting Pastor D there was a time
period during the early days of the
Protestant Reformation where there were
two rival popes and they were both
accusing each other of being
antichrists that's right so you have one
Pope accusing another pope of being the
Antichrist and the other Pope choosing
that one of being the Antichrist so it
is interesting when you st study the
history of what transpired there we do
have a study guide and it's called who
is the Antichrist and we'll be happy to
send that to anyone who wants to study
the subject further the number to call
is 800 83567 47 or you can dial pound
250 on your phone say Bible answers live
and then ask for that study guy by name
who is the Antichrist and you'll be able
to learn a lot about what this topic is
all about in the Bible next caller that
we have is Carlos and he's calling from
Texas he's got a question about 17
talking about the days of lot and Noah
Carlos welcome to the program good
evening pastors and thanks for your
ministry God Bless yeah thank
you my question is uh of Luke 17 Jesus
mentions both the days of lot and the
days of Noah in speaking of his coming
Kingdom and um I wanted to ask you about
the scenario after Noah uh leaves the
ark right and is saved essentially uh
and lot is pulled out of
Sodom both of them have an encounter
with wine I wondered if that has any um
significance prophetically for today or
for the future you know that's
interesting I did a study comparing a
lot and Noah and in many ways there's a
many similarities and many paradoxes
Noah has just Sons lot has just
daughters Noah saves his entire family
lot loses his family no one you know
he's separated from the cities lot moves
to the city a and uh you just you can
see a lot of parallels that are
happening there but it is true that a
lot drinks wine and he sleeps with his
daughters and has Moab and Ammon and
Noah drinks wine and he stumbles around
naked and curses his
grandson and son so um yeah I've got a
whole studying that and what it all
means is I'm not sure yet but there are
a lot of interesting parallels they're
almost like opposites of course when
Jesus mentions that he's talking about
what was happening in society at that
time what was happening in the days of
Noah you had violence full in the earth
it says every imagination of the heart
is evil continually you have the time of
of lot there in the city of Sodom and
the other cities surrounding the area
where they had plenty to eat uh they
were lazy they were involved in um you
know all kinds of sexual misconduct and
uh morality uh issues and you know
that's sort of a description of what's
happening in our world today things are
falling apart all around us so I think
that's an important lesson connected
there next caller that we have is uh
Dana listening in Nevada and Dana has a
question about uh the chronological
order of the scriptures Dana welcome to
the program hi my question is regarding
Revelation chapter 13 veres 3 and 5 and
power was given unto him to continue for
40 and two months but in verse three
says that and I saw one of his heads as
it were wounded to death why the order
is that way my son understood that the
the 42 months are
followed after the
wound yeah oh do you want to take yeah
when you when you look at some of these
passages especially in Revelation 13 not
everything as you mentioned is given in
chronological order Rob
Clues are given and these Clues are very
important to help identify who the power
is now in Bible prophecy a beast
represents a political power uh this
first piece of Revelation 13 is both got
a political component but also a
religious component and it says that he
would rule for 42 months uh there were
30 days in a Hebrew uh month and uh you
times that out 30 * 42 come to
1260 one prophetic day is equal to one
literal year so one of the clues given
in the verse is that this power would
rule for 1,260 years and then it would
receive a deadly wound now it's not
always written in strict chronological
order but it's giving us Clues and when
we put the clues together we can
identify who this power is not only this
power but also the other Beast that you
read about in Revelation 13 that comes
from the Earth again you put the clues
together and that is identified it's to
the US in Bible
prophecy thank you all right next caller
that we have is Leo in Arizona Leo
welcome to the program my question is on
Matthew
41-11 um especially the three did did
Satan not know who Jesus was when he was
trying to tempt them well I think Satan
definitely knew that this was the son of
God in fact at the beginning of jesus'
ministry often when he encountered
demon-possessed people they said we know
who you are so if the demons knew then
you can count on the devil know
uh the bigger question is did Jesus know
maybe not at first when the devil
appeared as an angel of Light you can
read in 2 Corinthians 11 Satan himself
can be transformed into an angel of
Light and but when he began to say if
you're the Son of God that sort of
betrayed that this was not an angel Sent
From Heaven of course when he finally
said Fall Down and Worship me then all
doubt was removed who this was and when
the devil said if you are the Son of God
he wasn't asking cuz he didn't know he
was wanting to cause Christ to question
the promise that he knew he was the son
of God and to exercise his power on his
own behalf contrary to the will of the
father so it was not a genuine question
there by any means it was a plot it was
part of a Temptation right all right
next caller that we have is uh Dana
listening from California you on the air
yes okay my question is um from the
Bible how can I pray more effectively I
know about the Lord's Prayer prayer but
is there other something another part of
the Bible that can help me pray more
effectively yeah I think there's a
number of passages you can look at um
you know the Bible says that we pray
without
ceasing Paul tells us and that doesn't
mean that you go around on your knees
all the time praying it means being in
an attitude of knowing that God is
always a prayer way many times during
the day I I'm just lifting prayers to
the Lord and talking to the Lord and
saying help me with this or pray for
that person and so prayer is also being
in continual communion with God it's not
just one prayer but there should also be
regular official prayer time where you
you kneel if you're able and you have
your personal devotions and you commit
your life to the Lord at the end of the
day you may be asking for mercy and
wisdom for the next day looking at some
of the prayers in the Bible that you see
you can see um you know Jacob is
wrestling with God In Prayer you can
read the prayers of Solomon the prayers
of Daniel the prayers of Hannah um
there's a lot of beautiful prayers
recorded in the Bible Nehemiah and that
I think also gives you a context about
prayer prayers don't have to be long you
look at the prayer of Elijah fire comes
down from heaven but the prayer is less
than 18 seconds I think you know Pastor
D I'm just looking at our books here
iach a book yeah that's right I wanted
to check on the name there we have a
book that talks about prayer and you
might find that helpful it's just call
teach us to pray and the number to call
for that is 800 835
6747 you can ask for the book teach us
to pray or di pound 250 and say Bible
answers live ask for the book by name if
you're outside of North America just
visit our website just amazingfacts.org
and you'll be able to get a lot more
information over there thank you Dina
next caller that we have is uh Nell in
California asking about what does the
Bible say about competitive Sports now
welcome to the
program hi thank you pastors yeah I was
wondering what does the Bible say about
competitive Sports because some
Christians seem to feel that um you
should not participate in any types of
competitive Sports you know even tennis
basketball or watch them um and some
Christian writers also would say the
same things according to what they say
so what does the Bible say about it and
what can we as Christians participate in
all right well if you're talking about
what does Bible say um there are
principles in the Bible that I think you
can apply to
sports Paul you
know Paul freely uses Sports references
he talks about I do not box the air he
says I do not run as though uh I'm not
trying and he says if you're can run the
race run to win and so you know Paul
incorporates and you got to keep in mind
the Greek culture had greatly influenced
the Hebrews and the the Romans and
sports were a big part of that it's
where you get the word gymnasium comes
all the way back from them so Paul uses
sport analogies a lot he doesn't
necessarily say anything negative about
sports but he does talk about the the
spirit and the mind of Christ a lot of
sports in the competition it's not the
idea of just getting exercise but it's
almost like um you know there's violence
and I think Christians ought to avoid
any kind of violent Sports I think that
uh when an emphasis is made on on
winning and the trophies and the pride
that's not uh the spirit of Christ u
Pastor Ross and I maybe confession is
good for the soul but bad for the
reputation we play ret ball together we
don't make a big deal about who wins I
get over it in about five minutes but we
we try to you keep scored so you can
know when the game ends so it's a great
exercise there's there's nothing
inherently wrong with getting exercise
where there's a sport connected but
there's some principles that you can
apply to different sports that may be a
guide you know I think some sports are
just geared to hurting people I mean
there's sort of these combative Sports
where it's just they just hitting each
other trying to knock each other out
it's even one step more you might say in
boxing where it's it's just violent and
it's goal is to hurt people I don't
think Christian should be involved in
anything like that it just feeds that
mindset of of of anger and violence and
you know we we don't want that exercise
is great and Paul says bodily exercise
profits but godliness profits more uh
unfortunately you know some of the
sports if like professional football and
I'm probably going to get letters on
this a lot of those guys suffer injuries
that car they carry with them through
their lives so it doesn't build their
bodies up it often breaks their bodies
down so you know that clearly I think is
not a healthy thing for a Christian to
engage in all right very good thank you
you uh do we have time for one more
Pastor Doug uh we do if it's quick all
right let's see we've got uh Matthew in
Tennessee Matthew we got about a minute
and your question this evening hi
Pastors in uh Mark 7:19 and The New
American Standard Bible it says
parenthetically that uh thus he made all
foods clean and then in the King James
version it doesn't say that it kind of
makes me not trust the other transl I
don't know if did the translator just
add that I guess is is my question yeah
there's a manuscript where they've added
that um and Jesus said that what goes in
your mouth doesn't defile you it goes in
and it comes out thus purging all Meats
in King James it just means your body
you know basically purges the food that
you eat that's not how you get defiled
and then someone uh took the liberty of
saying in saying this Jesus declared all
foods clean that is not in the original
manuscripts in the Greek most
manuscripts I should say but uh friends
we're out of time for this segment of
the program I always like to remind
people we sign off in two stages stay
tuned stand by we're going to go through
some rapid fire Internet Bible questions
God bless and we'll study together again
next
week thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing fa
International a faith-based Ministry
located in Granite Bay
California Hello friends and welcome
back to Bible answers live we're going
to answer your email questions if you'd
like to send us an email with your Bible
question it is B questions
amazingfacts.org just B questions
amazingfacts.org Pastor Doug first
question in Deuteronomy 1426 God seems
to endorse drinking alcohol is this
understanding accurate when he talks
about strong drink there he's not
talking about alcohol they used to
condense their grape juice dehydrated if
you will and uh then they'd reconstitute
it when they got to their destination
because the liquid's very heavy uh they
would take this grape juice and sort of
dehydrate it into a syrup and then as
they traveled they'd get to the place
where the feast is they'd reconstitute
it that's why I said you could drink the
strong drink don't think strong alcohol
think strong concentrated okay Sherman
is asking can you please explain exp the
sequence of events you have the wicked
bowing the knee and confessing that God
is righteous and then suddenly
surrounding the New Jerusalem trying to
attack it they're going to be
overwhelmed with a sense of their guilt
and his power and the Wicked Will bow
before God's Throne Jesus said and Paul
says the time is coming when every knee
will bow and every tongue will confess
to God and this is that moment but then
when they realize that this it's um
hopeless in desperation Satan will try
to rally them to attack the city when
they realize they've been condemned in
the Judgment they'll think what have we
got to lose and this demonstrates their
hearts are still not changed and God has
no option but to judge and Destroy them
and that's when the fire and brimstone
rain down forms a lake of fire and
they're all cast into this Lake of Fire
okay next question that we have Bradley
is asking how many prophecies still need
to be fulfilled before the seven last
plagues can start Jesus said the gospel
of the Kingdom will be preached in all
the world for witness then the end will
come the beast power is going to make a
law compelling people to worship a
certain way that has not happened and so
I'm you know there's probably several
other prophecies I'm I'm not thinking of
offhand we're seeing them being
fulfilled right now and uh I I'd say
stay tuned but we're going to see things
happen very quickly in the near future
till next week we'll study God's word
stay close to
Jesus Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions